being nice is Roi positive it is
traveling it is be known it is leverage
the ability to be not nice politicking
on the defense always wins up front
which is why people are seduced by it
but it never wins the long game you're
winning the Sprint for about 40 seconds
but you never win the marathon of what's
being played here it is now compounded
because information about us travels at
a level we've never seen before being a
dick in Portland in 1974 was super fine
because you could move to Minnesota that
information now travels with us at scale
you don't even want to know how much of
a jerk your great great grandfather was
all that stuff is lost in history all of
our baggage here forever and I am just
fascinated by the fact that the most
simple of traits now is the fundamental
game we're playing that is crazy to me
as we go more Jetsons the people that
know how to play like The Flintstones
are going to win literally I believe the
manners that your great great
grandparents have are far more suited
for where we're going than the majority
of us you were documenting your entire
life at scale forever